my son has not made money in terms of
this thing about uh what are you talking
about
China uh yeah he has and looks like
Joel's also rolling in the deal now it
began in July 2017 during Hunter's
Infamous takedown of a Chinese business
associate now at the time Biden's son
warned that individual that he was
sitting with his father and that if the
commitment wasn't fulfilled he said he
would make certain that between the the
man sitting next to him and every person
he knew and knows and my ability to
forever hold a grudge that you will
regret not following his Direction well
according to oversight committee chair
James comr the threat worked just a few
days later five million dollars flowed
in from a Chinese affiliate to Hudson
West which is a company that Hunter
founded that same day Hudson West sent
$400,000 to a separate company also
owned by Hunter now some of that money
was sent to Joe's brother James and his
wife Sarah it's like a family tree of
corruption well what about the rest of
it a few days later Sarah Biden cut a
check to Joe Biden for
$40,000 the memo line of the check said
loan
repayment loan repayment joining me now
is nuke Gingrich former Speaker of the
House Fox News contributor you don't
really need to be a forensic accountant
to figure out what's going on here I
mean it it's not lost on any of us I
don't think that the the math does check
out on that famous line 10% for the big
guy um what other family operates like
this maybe the clintons but this is just
obvious
look look I think the most interesting
question historically that we're now
faced with is how long can the New York
Times And The Washington Post avoid
every single example of Clinton of Biden
corrup corruption remember Biden not
only just got we were told this week he
got another check uh from China earlier
we were told that he got a $200,000
check from his brother from China well
we've now been told that there's some
880,000
plus uh emails under false names that he
used while vice president there at the
National Archives I mean at what point
does this be become so obviously the
most corrupt Administration in American
history that even his allies at the New
York Times And The Washington Post have
to finally break down and decide they're
going to start assigning reporters and
doing what they should be doing if they
were actually really
newspapers well n here's what the
Democrats are saying in response to this
news you'll be shocked two brothers loan
each other money they pay it back not an
office end of story one brother gives
one brother money the other brother pays
it back no one is elected at all they're
both private citizens what are we
talking about yeah okay oh well it could
be this it could be that we think it's
this we think that no evidence we're
back to the same
thing nude it's not like the pot of
money is fungible
here they all have individual Talent you
know that that warrants that kind of
money
easy look for the average American there
is an easy common sense
question if these guys were named Joe
Wilmington would they have gotten the
money out of China would they have
gotten the money out of Romania would
they have gotten the money out of Russia
would they have gotten the money out of
Ukraine would they have gotten the money
out of Kazakhstan no person in America
except some hardle weeb uh believes that
this money went for any reason
except that Joe Biden was a major
political force and that he was
basically trading on his name and that
his family was getting wealthy off of
his name uh and that he did things that
aren't expl you know he now has three
times as many emails as Hillary Clinton
did that are from a fake name I mean
this is an astonishing in in a normal
world
the entire apparatus of the justice
department would be going nuts tearing
this apart if his name was Richard Nixon
this would now be a gigantic Scandal and
he would be right on the edge of
impeachment I mean let's just be clear
only the
desperation of the establishment to
avoid Donald Trump winning is allowing
them to prop up what is clearly a
corrupt totally dishonest and cruely
every day lying family who are closer to
The Sopranos than they are to George
Washington yeah 82,000 Pages worth of
these private emails new that's all all
right um new it's great to see you
tonight thank you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else